[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD."
WHILE JESSE WATTERS.
TRUMP'S OLD LAWYER MICHAEL
COHEN, CONVICTED LIAR AND TAX
CHEAT ABOUT TO HEAD TO PRISON
FOR THREE YEARS.
BEFORE LEAVING HE BECAME THE
STAR WITNESS FOR THE DEMOCRATS
IN THEIR IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> I HAVE LIED.
BUT I'M NOT A LIAR.
I HAVE DONE BAD THINGS.
BUT I AM NOT A BAD MAN.
JESSE: I'M SURE YOU ARE NOT.
COHEN SYSTEMATICALLY DESTROYED
DEMOCRAT TALKING POINTS.
HE HELPED PUNCTURE THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION NARRATIVE.
>> QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED
WHETHER I KNOW OF DIRECT
EVIDENCE THAT MR. TRUMP OR HIS
CAMPAIGN EXCLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
I DO NOT.
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
MR. TRUMP DID NOT DIRECTLY TELL
ME TO LIE TO CONGRESS.
JESSE: IF COHEN DID HAVE THE
GOODS ON THE PRESIDENT MUELLER
WOULD HAVE CUT A DEAL WITH HIM.
HE DROVE A STAKE THROUGH THE
HEART OF THE CLINTON'S FINANCE
DOSSIER.
THE CENTER PIECE WAS TRUMP SENT
COHEN TO PRAGUE TO HATCH THE
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO PRAGUE?
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN TO PRAGUE
OTHER CZECH REPUBLIC.
JESSE: HE SAID HE HAD NO
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP DIRECTED
ROGER STONE TO MAKE CONTACT WITH
WIKILEAKS.
>> DO YOU HAVE NOR THAT THE
PRESIDENT DIRECTED ROGER STONE
TO MAKE CONTACT WITH WIKILEAKS?
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF THAT.
JESSE: COHEN SAID STONE HAD
ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT STONE
KNEW JUST ABOUT THE SAME TIME
EVERYBODY ELSE KNEW BECAUSE
JULIAN ASSANGE POSTED ON TWITTER
THAT HE WAS ABOUT TO DROP
SOMETHING.
SO THERE IS NOTHING THERE.
SPEAKING OF NOTHING THERE.
COHEN DESTROYED THE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ALLEGATION AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
REMEMBER STORMY DANIELS WAS PAID
FOR HER SO-CALLED STORY IN THE
FALL OF 2016?
THESE THIS HAPPEN WHEN YOU ARE
AS RICH AND FAMOUS AS DONALD
TRUMP IS.
YOU PAY FOR NEGATIVE ALLEGATIONS
TO GO AWAY TO PROTECT YOUR
PERSONAL AND FAMILY REPUTATION.
HE WOULD HAVE DAVID PECKER BUY
THE RIGHTS TO THE TORIES.
>> I WAS INVOLVED IN SELF OF
THESE CATCH AND KILL EPISODES.
THESE CATCH AND KILL SCENARIOS
EXISTED BETWEEN DAVID PECKER AND
MR. TRUMP LONG BEFORE I STARTED
WORKING FOR HIM IN 2007.
JESSE: TRUMP HAD BEEN DOING THIS
FOR OVER A DECADE.
THEREFORE THE STORMY PAYMENT WAS
NOT A CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURE.
IT WAS A PERSONAL EXPENDITURE
NOT A CRIME.
TRUMP HAD BEEN DOING IT FOR
YEARS AND WOULD HAVE DONE IT
REGARDLESS OF THE CAMPAIGN.
COHEN SAYS HE HAS NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP USING THE N WORD.
>> I TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT
OVER 300 TIMES.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ONE TIME A
RACIST COMMENT OUT OF HIS MOUTH
IN PRIVATE.
SO HOW DO YOU RECONCILE IT.
DO YOU HAVE PROOF OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS?
DO YOU HAVE TAPE-RECORDINGS OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS?
>> NO, SIR.
JESSE: COHEN CONTINUED TO KNOCK
DOWN AN ANTI-TRUMP CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF
THE PRESIDENT ARRANGING
PROCEDURES PORE WOMEN.
>> YOU KNOW OF ANY TIES TO
ALLEGED MOBSTERS PRESIDENT TRUMP
MAY HAVE.
JESSE: HE NEVER PAID FOR AN
ABORTION OR HAD A LOVE CHILD OR
HAD MOB TIES.
THANKS, MICHAEL.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THIS IS A
REVENGE PLOT.
SEE THE GUY BEHIND COHEN?
LANNY DAVIS.
THE CLINTON FIXER IS
REPRESENTING TRUMP'S OLD
FICTIONER.
THE FIX IS IN.
LANNY IS PROBABLY STILL GETTING
PAID BY THE CLINTONS OR SOME FAT
CAT CLINTON DONOR.
LANNY HAS BEEN LEAKING TO THE
MEDIA LIKE CRAZY.
THE DEMOCRATS STARTED THIS HIT
JOB WITH THE DOSSIER, THEN THE
WIRETAPS, THEN THE WITCH HUNT.
COHEN IS BEING USED.